das sind die letzten Schritte in ihrer
Heimat Ankara erst hat Ayse Celik noch
gewählt jetzt wird sie die Türkei
verlassen das Land in dem sie 30 Jahre
für Menschenrechte für die Rechte von
Frauen und der lgbtq-community gekämpft
hat
ich liebe mein Land und ich liebe es
hier zu leben ich möchte nicht gehen
aber wir werden dazu genötigt
[Musik]
Rückblick die Türkei steht vor der
Stichwahl die Opposition ist stark wie
nie schon während der Wahl haben wir
Eiche Celik begleitet sie ist Kurden und
eng verwandelt mit der prokurdischen HDP
weil gegen diese ein Verbotsverfahren
läuft stimmte sie für Kemal College zu
diesem Zeitpunkt hat Aische chillig noch
Hoffnung dass ich etwas ändern könnte
wir wollen das demokratische Bedingungen
geschaffen werden doch die erste Runde
der Wahl hat uns gezeigt dass der
Nationalismus vorne steht
[Musik]
direkt nach dem ersten Wahlgang setzt
eine Verhaftungswelle einen den
kurdischen Gebieten Journalisten
Politiker Künstler und Rechtsanwälte der
türkische Innenminister droht sollte
Erdogan an der Macht bleiben dann stehen
sie auf der Abschussliste ganz oben
kritische kurdische Anwälte wie Eiche
chillig am frühen Abend der Wahl Ankunft
am Berliner Flughafen das Ergebnis von
der Türkei aus zu verfolgen das wollte
sie nicht riskieren
ich bin müde es war die längste Reise
meines Lebens ich verstehe Menschen die
aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen des Land
verlassen aber in dieser Lage bin ich
doch nicht ich musste gehen entweder so
oder Gefängnis
wie lange in Deutschland bleiben wird
wovon sie leben will Fragen auf die Sie
noch keine Antwort hat denn noch läuft
die Wahl noch sind nicht alle Stimmen
ausgezählt noch gibt es Hoffnung dass
sie ihre Tochter in Ankara bald
wiedersieht
ja verstehe pass auf dich auf
vor
unterdessen am Wahlabend in Istanbul
noch bevor alle Stimmen ausgezählt sind
kürzlich Erdogan zum Sieger dann wird
mit er sich einem seiner Lieblingsthemen
der Hetze gegen die lgbtq-community denn
diese wie er es nennt perversen
Tendenzen wolle er aktiv bekämpfen kann
lgbtq in die AKP nein die MHP
unterwandern nein können Sie unsere
volksallianz unterwandern nein
[Musik]
Erdogan bleibt Präsident
Verabredung mit zwei lieben und zum
Staatsfeind erklärt wurden Ismail ist
schwul und ameder ist transsexuell beide
bekennen sich offen dazu die Rede von
Erdogan macht sie wütend was ein Sieg
nun für sie bedeutet wollen wir wissen
früher hatten sie Angst sich in unser
Leben einzumischen weil sie wussten dass
sie dafür vor Gericht bestraft werden
aber jetzt ist es so sie können uns
umbringen verbrennen und vergewaltigen
und sie werden dafür nicht bestraft
ist wie ein Massaker gegen uns schon
jetzt haben sie Angst sich außerhalb
ihres Viertels zu bewegen das könnte
sich weiter verschärfen wenn erdogan hat
neue Verbündete ein Bündnis aus
Faschisten und Islamisten das mit aller
Härte gegen die vorgehen will die sich
nicht zum traditionellen Familienbild
bekennen mit Erdogan
noch stärkerer Gegner gegenüber der noch
hasserfüllter ist
zurück in Berlin
Frust und Jubel über das Wahlergebnis
[Musik]
Aische armt
die LGBT Bewegung die kurdenbewegung
Juristen werden unter hohem Druck stehen
besonders diese Menschen werden jetzt
zum Schweigen gebracht
sie werden wohl die meisten
demokratischen Institutionen schließen
und eine große Hexenjagd wird beginnen
in der Türkei werden eiches schlimmste
Befürchtungen war keine Gnade werde er
walten lassen gegen seine Feinde gegen
den wohl prominentesten Inhaftierten der
Türkei den ex-vorsitzenden der
prokurdischen HDP
Erdogan ohne Zeit zu verlieren gleich in
dieser Nacht vor dem Präsidialamt klar
[Applaus]
ist der Terrorist der den Tod von 51
kurdischen Brüdern in diabakir
verursacht hat
dann skandiert die Menge Sella hart Team
Edam Hinrichtung für seller harty
Worte gäbe es dafür keine Sack zinakara
will ein enger Freund von demirtash er
ahnt nichts Gutes der Europäische
Gerichtshof hatte angeordnet die Haft
des brokkolischen Politikers aufzuheben
doch die türkische Staatsanwaltschaft
fordert weiter lebenslang
verglichen mit den heutigen
Haftbedingungen wird er weiter isoliert
werden das ist das was ihn erwarten wird
[Musik]
und das Klima in der Türkei werde sich
weiter verschärfen nicht nur für seinen
Freund
gerade für Frauen gestaltet sich das
Leben in der Türkei immer mir zur Hölle
doch ihre Mittel sind noch nicht
ausgeschöpft je härter die Regierung
wird umso härter wird ihr Kampf dagegen
weiter kämpfen das fällt Eiche chillig
in dieser Nacht Schwert
ändert das Leben deshalb dürfen wir die
Hoffnung nicht verlieren wir bemühen uns
aber ich weiß gerade auch nicht weiter
ein Gefühl das all jene die die
Opposition unterstützen Teilen dürften
[Musik]